this video is sponsored by surfsharkvpn
have you ever felt that you weren't
secure on the internet has your isp ever
sent you an email detailing your
browsing history ever see an online
video say unavailable in your country
well my friend consider yourself lucky
because my friend
you need a vpn and i just so happen to
be able to help
friend introducing surfsharkvpn by far
the most secure and easy to use
vpn service provider out there they do
it all they mask your ip address
uh connect to servers from different
countries automatically block over a
million malicious websites
online kind of like an antivirus encrypt
your data no matter what network you're
on oh and they have this unique
no logs policy meaning it is nearly
impossible for anybody to see your
browsing history so you can browse
with privacy if you've been considering
getting a vpn or changing from your
current one even
a little bit i highly highly recommend
surfsharkvpn
they offer unlimited downloads you heard
me unlimited
downloads across all of your devices no
matter what platform they are from a
console to your computer to your phone
and if you use the code mnb when
checking out you
my friend can get yourself 83 off and
three months free there it is you see it
on the screen i'm not joking get
yourself 83
off and three months free by using the
code mnb when you check out
my friends and now on to the video if
you've been watching for very long on
the channel
you'll know that so far i've pretty much
capitalized on theory videos about the
legend of zelda which is just what i'm
most passionate about and for those of
you who have been paying very close
attention i've expressed my desire and
willingness to annex
more than just zelda slash theory
content into the channel
however that does not mean that i have
mastered theory videos which was
evidenced to me pretty clearly in my
last
zelda one for those of you who watched
it you probably already
know what i'm talking about impa's
bracelet for those of you who haven't
seen it i recommend watching it now
actually since this video is kind of
going to be a part 2 or part 1.5
as i'm going to expound on what was
clearly rather confusing in it but i
won't be recovering what's already been
discussed in that video it's about
skyward sword's timeline manipulation
and
is pretty interesting in my opinion the
link to it will be on the screen and in
the description below so please feel
free to pause this video right now if
you haven't seen it and check it out and
then return right here of course
now then back to this video it was made
clear to me almost
instantly when i read the comments after
going live with that theory that people
were not exactly
on the same page as i was when i was
scripting the video to put it shortly
and it's 100 my fault i believe i have
analyzed the problem and have come to
the conclusion that it happened as a
result of my
inexperience since i'm still relatively
new to this platform what i'd like to do
in this video is explain what happened
for those interested in what happened
and add on to the aforementioned theory
with some more pieces of evidence that
will hopefully help those previously
confused to at least
understand where i'm coming from and yes
i fully understand that this does have a
slight chance of confusing people more
so fasten your timeline theory seat
belts guys
oh and one last thing i decided to do
this video because
ultimately i care about my viewers and i
care about my content
i always get people who don't agree or
who don't get it necessarily but
this video's comments went a little too
far in my opinion and it really bothers
me that i failed to deliver a script
worthy of my own standard and for that
i'd like to apologize to you
okay let's get into the content first
i'll quickly summarize what happened
that led to all the confusion in the
last video in my opinion
i believe the part about the bracelet
was taken wrongly because i assumed
everyone had the same understanding that
i did of skyward sword's past
you see i happen to believe pretty
strongly that skyward sword's past
did not happen yet at the beginning of
the game and just assumed everyone else
thought that too
they clearly did not and i know my
belief sounds confusing but let me
expound on that now which is what i did
not do in the last video from what i've
seen
people's main reasons for believing the
past has already happened are
one impulse bracelet and two the fact
that if you notice
you can actually see zelda in her
crystallized form if you peek behind the
doors located behind impa in the present
time
implying quite clearly that at least
some of the events in the past have
already taken place
however there are two main reasons why i
disagree or at least believe there are
too many discrepancies for it to be
explained away so cleanly as a linear
timeline
in the first place and most obviously
demise himself was defeated
in the past right you know the events
that take place at the end of the game
after which he was sealed away in the
master sword which was then
placed in a pedestal in the sealed
temple that we are able to see
once we return to the present after
these events
this already makes zero sense and here's
why the pedestal that link thrusts the
master sword into in the past
is not present in the present timeline
until the end of the game
if the events of the past had truly
happened as some people believe
due to seeing impa's bracelet and
zelda's crystallization at the beginning
of the game
then we should be able to see at least
the pedestal that the master sword has
supposedly already been placed in
but it's the opposite the pedestal is
nowhere to be found much less the master
sword which we know
link places right here in the past in
fact
if the master sword has already been
placed in the mysteriously disappearing
pedestal in the past
why then is the pre-master sword goddess
sword here on link's back
in the present you could say this is
because similarly to the impa bracelet
somehow it is the goddess sword's fate
to live this cycle but i'm sorry that
just doesn't add up
how and why would the master sword leave
its pedestal after being placed there in
the past
travel back upwards to skyloft enter
that pedestal
downgrade back to the goddess sword and
then transport itself back down to the
sealed temple in that pedestal and
upgrade back to the master sword all in
time for link and code to enter the
present timeline again after the events
of the end of the game
if that sounded confusing guys it's
because that is literally what it sounds
like to believe that the events of the
past
already happened at least in their
entirety clearly not all of them did but
i'm not done yet
point number two which some people did
bring up in the comments of the previous
video is the tree of life
fruit at a certain point in the game
link travels to the lenairu gorge and
meets the thunder dragon who is in dire
need of some life tree fruit the seed
for such a tree that would produce such
a fruit has been planted nearby
but it isn't growing in the gorge so
link takes the seed to the sealed temple
and
get this goes to the past to plant it in
the temple
of course it's fully grown by the time
he reaches the present
you can probably see where i'm going
with this the tree is not present in the
sealed temple before
this point in the present timeline it's
clear to me that the events of the past
have not happened yet
again at least not in their entirety and
this is what i mistakenly assumed
everyone understood when i scripted the
previous video
there are some people in the comments
who said that there's some sort of
explanation that entails the flow of
time happening differently depending on
who you are and what your destiny is
for instance impa's bracelet this
explanation implies that zelda already
had her past happen which is why you can
see the bracelet and zelda's crystalline
form at the beginning of the game
but this explanation literally breaks
itself
up because is it not link's destiny to
go back in time as well
is it not his destiny to plant the life
tree or to place the master sword in the
pedestal that isn't even
there by that exact train of logic
all of the things that link is destined
to do should already be visible
but yet we have a pedestal that doesn't
appear in the present or in the past
until link defeats demise in the past a
sword that goes from master sword form
to god of sword form back to master
sword form and from this pedestal in the
past to this pedestal and then back to
this pedestal in the present just in
time for the heroes to exit the gate of
time and a life tree that isn't present
in the present until link plants it in
the past
if you are trying to imply that impa's
bracelet is already on impa's arm
because it was zelda's destiny to give
it to her in the past
then you cannot explain the pedestal you
cannot explain the master sword you
cannot explain the existence of demise
and you cannot explain the life tree
either the past happened or it
didn't and when you have discrepancies
the only way to explain them
is with either multiple realities or
split timelines
or both and that brings me back to the
bracelet
the reason why i used it to disprove a
linear timeline when it
seemingly implies a linear timeline is
because of everything i just said in
this video
i hope this helped clear up some
confusions you may have had after
watching the first theory
and if so once again i'm sorry that i
didn't include it the first time
if not once again i'm also sorry about
that timelines are notoriously confusing
to talk about so
this all is perfectly understandable
from certain points of view
either way though thank you so much for
watching if you still have some
questions please feel free to leave them
in the comments below and i might be
able to answer some of them
similarly if you have a request for
anything you'd like me to cover in the
legend of zelda leave that in the
comments as well
please consider giving this video a like
so it gets spread around especially to
those who are confused about zelda's
timelines and be sure to subscribe to
the channel for more theories and
nintendo content to come
as always huge thanks to my amazing
bandit crew who make
my day every single day if you're
interested in joining the ranks of my
elite and consequently helping me put
food on my table
please feel free to press that join
button below any video or follow the
links in the description below to my
patreon or merch pages
oh i almost forgot some of you
deciphered
ending eight of my create your own
nintendo direct bravo to you
i am a man of my words so it's time for
your announcements
that took a lot of work and i'm proud of
you guys for those of you who may be
confused by what i'm talking about just
check out the create your own nintendo
direct i made you'll see what i mean
that's all i've got for this one guys so
as always i hope you have a wonderful
rest of your day
this is mass nintendo bandit signing out
[Music]
you